yeah okay my so today we are waxing each
other's chests because apparently I
don't know what a bad idea is anymore
oh my god we're playing a game it's
called wax for wax an expert is going to
put a strip on both of us oh and he'll
rip it off of me then I'll rip it off of
him I'm slowly starting to realize that
this is a really bad idea
I mean how painful can waxing really be
right I think the chest is very painful
it's a very sensitive area you may feel
like your skin is coming off as well how
hot is the wax that's not that hot oh
that's frickin hot oh my god that's a
hundred degrees nothing to be afraid of
honey
oh my god I did that really good just
kill this one shot me in that shoulder
people do that on the private parts yes
a round one was awful
I'm running into the office to see if
anyone else wants to play the game hey
Jared you gonna play wax for wax see
what what are you guys doing well that
neither of us are bleeding yet yes she
seems like she knows what she's doing
though I on the other hand feeling good
I don't feel good Zach I've got a
meeting to run to race ready no sure
final thoughts
this was chaos there was weird at the
same time like with each rip there was a
bit of an adrenaline rush I felt a lot
that's uh I mean I I regret it I
definitely have to do some kind of
maintenance because this looks awful I
look like an idiot I think I'm just
gonna let mine ride I'm just gonna yeah
yes as a stylist your summer look my
summer look in fact I'm gonna have to
groom to keep this going oh I think a
day